okay thanks
thank you
uh my pleasure to be introduced by adam
uh and uh to be uh invited to speak here
i'm gonna talk about uh
work on investing in kind of
how what can you do with this uh
the training method we all use all the
time just running gradient descent or
something just during work uh with
emmanuel pt iran and colin i should say
that um during the course of writing
this paper three of my four co-authors
had babies
um
so
if you want some kind of fertility omen
or something i'm open to collaboration i
don't know if you're uh
a pretty good success rate so uh okay um
yeah so the
the the basic question uh we're gonna be
talking about is like what do you we
have this learning paradigm basically
all of uh learning we just heard the
entire talk i don't think uh ludwig even
mentioned how
any of these models get trained because
it's kind of obvious i mean all our
learning is basically done by coming up
with some model and then running some
kind of uh version of grading descenders
to cast the great and descend on it
and these models are usually some kind
of deep networks but you can think of
any differentiable model okay and the
question we're going to be asking today
is you know how powerful is this
learning paradigm what kind of learning
problems can be learned by coming up
with some model and then just running
grading descent of it okay
and i want to um so one way to think
about it is essentially what we're doing
here right we're
solving an optimization problem see if
this works okay we're solving
optimization problem we're minimizing uh
the loss and some functions so it looks
like we're just doing erm but i want to
emphasize this is definitely not
uh the same as erm right so for one
reason this is not the same as just
doing erm
is that the you know we're using some
specific optimization procedure on a
problem that's generally non-convex and
very crazy and
we um
generally we're not going to find the
global minima and it's not just some
technicality oh that we might not find
the gold minimum but yeah i mean usually
we do we really can't pretend even that
we find our goal minima because this
gives us completely wrong uh um
wrong answers right so in particular if
we could actually
do erm if we could find the global
minima
of the lost in the neural network we
could pretty much learn anything right
so any
uh um
and um
uh any computable any colonial
computable function can be represented
by a polynomial size neural network and
so if we just train the polysized neural
network we could learn the class of open
animal functions pretty much anything we
might ever want to learn um
and so this is just this gives us the
wrong answer um
the
um
um and in particular
i mean pretending this it it's also
avoids kind of the question
um because the real question to me is
like what are these type of things i
mean we train with neural nets we
actually have lots of success what is
where is the success coming from how
come we can actually you know uh get all
these amazing results by training neural
nets and the success is somehow related
in a way you know there's some magic
property uh of these problems that we're
solving that make him trainable by
grading descent to a neural net
and we don't know what this magic
property is and
again pretending that we're i mean this
whole matter party rests with some what
makes it so we actually get to this
global minima
and so it's not
we're not going to get any insight for
that at all by just pretending we do
hear him but the other reason we can't
really pretend uh this is very different
from rm so what we talked about is how
it's weaker than actually doing erm but
in some sense it's also
stronger so we know that many cases we
can actually effectively learn with
gradient descent
on models that training them with erm
doesn't make any sense so over
parameterized models
many of the models we use have many many
more parameters than training points for
such a model just doing erm is not is
not actually a good learning rule there
are many empirical skill advisors that
do not generalize well
but when we actually train with grading
descent we frequently do get to um
to uh
solutions that do generalize well um and
we understand this you know quite well
in some problems and some simple
problems the simplest problem you can
think of as a
an over parameterized linear regression
problem and completely nonsensical you
know just getting zero error doesn't get
anything we're trying gradient descent
corresponds to uh finding a normal
solution which might actually behave
very well okay um
and so
the
again pretending we're just doing erm
completely ignores that right so that
might also give us a lot of power
so
uh hopefully what i convince you is that
really asking what can we learn by
grading descent is very different from
us asking what can we learn with grading
by uh erm and this is the
um
the questions uh we're going to be
looking at uh today so
you know our learning paradigm is we
just come up with a differentiable model
maybe represented by a neural network uh
and our learning role is then just doing
uh kind of differential model maybe
initialization and our learning rule is
right just running grading descent or
maybe stochastic grading descent um
on this learning rule um
you know what type of learning problems
can we learn what's the kind of power of
that okay any questions so far
okay um okay so now there's some issue
um also with
how do we run exactly when i say grading
descent so we will distinguish between
using grading sentence stochastic granny
center in particular this is uh going to
be an important point to ask and one
question you can ask also which is
natural is is there a difference
actually between running stochastic
gradient scent or batch gradient scent
large bed large mini batch when you send
small medium background in descent and
this is also a definitely uh something
we'll address
okay but this is a pillar to maybe think
about and this is also what led us to
ask these questions about what's
learnable with grading descent why is it
useful to even ask what type of problems
are learnable using some model so one
question that uh we asked and many uh
others asked is
this question of what's learnable with
the with uh grading descent on the
neural net that's not learnable using a
kernel so this is a very natural
question to ask and this is exactly this
type of question where you're asking
what's the kind of learning power you
have a general paradig learning paradigm
my learning paradigm is maybe doing
gradient descent in a neural network and
somebody else learning paradigm is um
training choosing a kernel and and uh
fitting a model with that kernel so with
uh uh regularization respect that kernel
um you know can i learn anything that
that by picking a model that the other
person cannot learn by picking a kernel
okay
um
and this is of course motivated there's
been lots of discussion about viewing
neural networks approximating neural
networks uh
is uh uh
um is kernels right so if you uh think
in a certain regime the neural network
kind of never escapes its linear
approximation in that case uh basically
what you have is just the kernel method
this neuron tangent kernel and then uh
learning just corresponds to solving
this uh um uh l to regularized problem
or kernel problem okay um
and this is kind of a very from my
perspective very disappointing view of
uh
of deep learning because it would
suggest that oh what we can the things
we can explain using this view is only
things we can only do with kernels we
already know how to learn with kernels
what's the point and we want to go
beyond that
so can we go beyond that um
and the the short answer is uh uh yes
there are many problems uh that are
learnable using uh grading science from
neural network but not learnable using
any kernel and there's been a lot of
work in that i'm not going to go over
this table this is more of an
advertisement we try to really go and
collect all the uh work showing the
separation you can uh look at our paper
for uh all the details um
but uh one thing i um say is that many
of these separations are not like as
extreme like what they show is that you
can get um you can learn with both
methods but maybe you need more samples
with the kernel method or maybe you know
the error you can get there's some
difference in errors you can get we
really ask asking you have like an
extreme separation where you can just
learn something perfectly well with the
neural network by grading the center
neural network and not learn uh pretty
much at all uh using a kernel and
uh this is the uh and the answer is yes
and you can do that i see that in a
fairly easy problem this problem is
biased as far as parities right so here
we have um the output is uh just a
way okay
uh the output is just a parity over a
log n and this input dimension many bits
and the bits though are biased so each
bit has a
bias of you know it's more likely to be
ones and one or zero it's more likely to
be one okay
so this problem is actually very easy
because there's still enough correlation
all the bits and that are participating
apparently have enough correlation to
the target they can easily identify them
okay uh but uh um i cannot do this with
the kernel method the kernel method
cannot learn parodies of this size no
politicized kernel method no current
method can do this with polynomial uh
sample size so the question is can you
do it also by training a neural network
and the answer is yes the reason i'm
showing you is neural network is because
i think it captures kind of what you can
do with gradient descent okay so what
happens in this neural network
there are two pathways to the output one
is through just a linear function and
this picks up so the first what's going
to happen is we're going to pick up all
the correlations all the bits are
actually correlated to the output so
this pathway okay so that's kind of the
first step of grading descent but then
after we did that we're going to
actually not use this pathway at all
because there's another pathway that
goes through a kind of
a parity that's hard coded into the
network right so again we don't know
what the support of the parody is but
that's going to be picked up in the
first step
and then we're actually using these
things to come for a completely
different thing right so this is
something that that um
that kernels inherently cannot do yes
all the bits are burst so all the bits
are biased yeah so so we'll mention
maybe then if only the bits in the
support are biased uh that's also cannot
be uh um can't be learned by kernel and
can super easily be learned by like
anything right uh there uh in this case
but we did want to restrict her to
problems where the input distribution is
fixed so we're not leaking information
through the input distribution actually
i'll mention that at the very end if i
have time which i probably will not uh
but yeah so here all the bits are biased
the thing is this bias just creates
because all the bits are biased the
other bits and parity are biased so i
have that maintain some correlation
uh uh there's a polynomial correlation
between each uh uh bit in the in the
actual parity and the output okay okay
the the point here is that what we did
here um
is uh sorry so what we did here is we
kind of used gradient descent to do like
in the first step it's doing something
fairly different in the second step and
the first step is kind of identifying
which uh
which bits are linearly correlated and
then in the second step it's actually
you know
saying oh i can actually use their
parity it's hardcoded and and doing that
and that's kind of the type of way we're
going to be using uh grading descent
later on so the bottom line here is here
uh uh this shows an example where you
can uh
you can get most a polynomial um
edge and no kernel can get better than
simple normal diminishing edge uh and we
can learn perfectly with the gradient
descent but the thing is that
in knowing this example we actually had
to devise this uh show this uh uh neural
net and build it and then analyze it and
analyze very same it was actually kind
of a pain and in doing this i realized i
mean can we just have a relate training
with grading descent to models we're
already familiar with so that in order
to prove these kind of guarantees in
order to argue about what's possible
with grading center and what's not
possible gradients and we can just refer
to results we already know or to just
the simple models that are easier to
analyze okay and this is what we're
going to be uh trying to do here
yes
no so the paper from uh
uh danielle and malach did what was
mentioned here the uh the
um
the bits are completely that apparently
yeah but the this the input the diff
the differences in that paper the input
distribution itself this distribution
over x leaks the output
so the input distribution is not it's
not a fixed input distribution it's
independent of the function
here the
it's a mixture half the time it's
exactly the paragraph right
and the other half the time it's a just
a parody on some uniform assignments
now in their paper the the input
distribution of x was was an extra
distribution
where half the time it was
it's just those bits right which means
that i can ignore the target
and just look at the input
parity of all those things distribution
but okay so central perspective the
difference is this is not
if the input distribution you have if
the learning problem is learning your
parities you don't know what the parity
is then the input distribution is not
fixed here the input distribution is
fixed
right so the input distribution here
doesn't have anything to do with the
parity it's fixed
okay
okay
so that's what i wanted here i mean the
details i should say that the d we'll
maybe go back to the end i don't want at
this point to dwell so much with the
technical level that's the difference
between uh
danielle and malakin here and and this
work right so and also if you wanted a
simpler example you could just use a
single value acquisition you know we
know the gradient descent
yeah so so we okay so again so that's uh
i i really rather not go into this now i
just said there are many uh separations
and i think the single railroad is uh in
this uh table somewhere and it's in fact
the first thing in this uh table okay uh
so for single release we get a
separation but it's not a separation
between uh not having any edge or just
having an arbitrary program a small edge
and having uh
uh and being able to perfectly learn it
you can get an edge for a single reload
also with a kernel it's just not going
to be
you you can get a
exponential epsilon
what exponential and epsilon so let's
let's talk about it uh
exponentially what's epsilon
oh right but you can get for any
constant i can get any constant error
with the kernel okay so it's just as i
said it's a different type i'm sorry so
that's it i mean this is like there's
lots of different separations here and
we i mean i'm just showing an example
result for one particular separation i
mean this
okay um
it's a question there
okay sorry there was a question okay
let's uh
uh oh wow
okay we haven't even started the talk so
uh
where are we okay um right okay so let's
start the talk so the question is what
can we learn with the uh um greatness
and differentiable model uh and in
particular can we go beyond kernels we
already know that we can go beyond
kernels uh oops
but maybe we can learn anything you know
maybe anything that's learnable we can
uh encode this grading descent or uh you
know what i mean by anything that's
learnable anything that's learnable
using some method using m samples um so
this is what i'll refer to as pack
learning and i completely ignore the
fact that these letters actually mean
anything uh
any words i just mean when they say pac
learning i just mean learning based on
them samples or maybe anything that's
learnable using polynomial time with m
samples
um
or maybe at least anything that's
runnable using statistical queries right
so that's going to be a uh
something we're going to be talking
about a lot is learning with statistical
queries meaning i only query kind of the
uh uh instead of getting samples i only
query the distribution by uh uh getting
approximate uh expectations we'll uh see
the definition in a second okay so in
particular in all these things what
we're going to be trying to do just to
get the the setting we're going to be
trying to relating learning methods um
and to keep things simple we're going to
be sticking with binary labels and
squared laws so our goal and all this is
to find some predictor f that has
a
small uh
small squared loss
with respect to the distribution and
we're going to measure the error of
um
in if we have an input distribution
algorithm the error of the distribution
is just the expected error uh over the
expected error that this algorithm is
going to get for this distribution
expectation is over the sampling or any
random choices the algorithm makes and
there's also a supreme here some of our
methods are going to be
non-deterministic in the sense that
they're going to have all kinds of like
allowed choices it can make like for
example if i'm saying erm erm is not a
specific method there may be many rms
they can choose any one of them right so
this is an arbitrary choice that i'll
make this superman was over all these
allowed choices the algorithm can make
and what we're going to really be saying
what i'm saying is that how to simulate
uh algorithms in one class using
algorithms with a different class so
we'll denote it by saying that i can
ensure smaller error uh with the uh
where's my it can store smaller error
with class c prime than class c
if for any method in class c there's a
method in class c prime so that for all
distributions the error i can get with
this uh c prime type method is not much
worse but not worse by more than delta
an error i can get with class c so this
is a very very strong notion of being
able to simulate one you know one class
of models with another so in particular
we mentioned sq learning and pac
learning right so we all know that we
can simulate pac learning with sq
learning right so sq learning we answer
uh we learn by receiving um uh tau
accurate answers uh to expectation
respect to the source distribution we
can get such tau accurate answers by
actually sampling uh which pack learning
method can do it can sample and answer
that so in particular if i have a number
of samples it's roughly uh k log k over
uh tau squared i can simulate any sq
method that makes k queries each of them
with accuracy tau okay so this is um the
type of results we want to get but again
we want to get that now and we know that
very well the relationship is packed in
sql we want to get them for grading
descent okay so let's define what we
mean by grading descent um
so um right so grading descent we have
we some differentiable model f uh we
have initialization w naught can be
maybe fixed or maybe a random
initialization but fixed distribution
over initializations and we just start
with initialization and keep updating
based on negative gradient uh steps and
for simplicity we're taking here fixed
step size any step size the step size is
not going to play any role here okay
and the gradient is just you know the
gradient of the loss with respect to uh
uh to the parameter
now of course what we um
actually do is we don't calculate the
expectation of the actual population we
don't have access to that so stochastic
grading descent we um
refers to taking each step based on the
that calculated in a single sample x and
y drawing from the distribution okay and
now
the parameters here is you know how many
iterations they do which is also the
number of uh symbols and the parameters
and
what we're actually going to be looking
what we've done is practice when one
thing really want to pay attention is
what happens when you change the mini
batch what's the winning change mini
batch right so it means i get
more and more accurate gradient
estimates so my my grading estimates are
now calculated not based on single
points but each step i base it on b
point so that's another parameter here
and
as i mentioned the important thing i
want to ask is what is the effect of
this b so in particular in kind of
predecessor to this work two of my uh
co-author uh uh emmanuel and colin um
i already noted that this the batch size
plane plays an important role here and
what they uh showed is that with a with
pure sgd with a batch size of one
they showed how to actually simulate any
pack learning algorithm so we're as
powerful attack we can kind of really
learn everything in some sense
and we're going to revisit this result
today and on the other hand if i take
gradients on the population so if i have
an infinite bet size then they show that
you cannot go beyond the skew right so
in particular you're strictly weaker
than pack right so there is a gap here
but
um so one question we can ask is what
happens in the middle what happens if we
have for example like a polynomial batch
size or you know some other reasonable
back size uh can we actually simulate
pack or can we not like when does it
become impossible to simulate pack here
and also what can we do maybe beyond
that point i mean if we have a maybe we
can simulate attack we can do something
else but it turns out there's another
very relevant parameter here and that's
the accuracy for calculations so
um
colin and manuel's uh uh results
especially the negative result rather
than the fact that our our accuracy we
have polynomial accuracy in other words
we have logarithmic number of bits of
precision right so all our gradients are
only calculated up to some polynomial
resolution rows what do we mean by that
we don't actually get back the actual
gradient we get back the gradient what
we use is only the gradient up to some
row okay and again you can think of
log rho is a number of bits of precision
in particular actually in our results
what the way we'll think about it is
just that what you get is a estimate of
the gradient with low grow bits of
precision okay um so you can
i i prefer thinking of rose really the
numerical precision you're working with
but in that case limiting yourself to
polynomial rho again that's only
logarithmic number of bits seems very uh
weak right so what happens if you have
uh if you allow yourself slightly better
precision than that right
do the results change and how do the
results suspect this
um
and this is all for
stochastic gradient descent another
variant we can ask is here we're using
fresh examples at each iteration um what
happens if we really go to just a full
batch variant so the full batch variant
we collect examples and then just do
gradient take every step in the same
examples so formally this is exactly the
same before except that the the set the
random set of examples whoop where i
mean the random set of examples are used
in each iteration instead of being
independent usuration is just fixed what
happens there how does that affect the
results right so i mean does that break
things down or maybe i can even i can
learn also in this uh paradigm
um
and so this is kind of the uh the
questions we'll ask and let's we'll
start with minibatch sgd so with the
stochastic variant and then return to
full batch later in particular as i said
i want to relate this uh to uh uh
pack and sq so we already know that in
this extreme corner uh when we batch
size of one i can simulate pack and then
you already spill the beans and and uh
ruin the entire tension here and tell
you the answer so what i'll show you is
that actually you can simulate pack with
any batch size as long as you have uh
a good enough precision and the
precision you need is
you know and you only need polynomial
precision so logarithmic number of bits
in particular need your precision to be
roughly one over b okay and this is
fairly tight
once your precision is too low so once
uh
rho square becomes more than one over b
roughly or you know in other words if
you have fixed precision once your batch
size becomes bigger than one over rho
squared then you stop being able to
simulate the pack you cannot go beyond
this cube but you can still do a skew
right remember that this there is a
positive result here because at least
you can do a sq so this kind of gives us
almost full characterization of what we
can do with grading descent there's a
small gap here but roughly speaking if
the precision is good enough relative to
the batch size we can simulate pack
otherwise we can simulate ice cube and
and that's it
okay so
um let's see how how we get this and
as if i didn't already
attack you with enough acronyms i'm
going to introduce yet another model and
this model is what we call mini batch
statistical query learn so what's
meaning about statistical query learning
it's the way you would actually
implement sqlearning like if i actually
ask you to implement sqlearning how do
you implement sqlearning it's not like
you can you're not going to calculate
the expectation of the population and
then add some adversarial noise because
you can't actually calculate this
expectation of population the way you're
going to work is each time you're going
to answer a query based on probably a
sample from the population okay so uh in
the mini sq model the algorithm kind of
works in a similar way that's
statistical queries but each statistical
query is answered based on an empirical
average of b examples
from the population again with some
tolerance or precision tau and i think
prefer think about in terms of precision
so numerical precision tau okay and an
important point here is that now we're
going to ask these queries in rounds so
we get to ask
p
scalar queries or p dimensional vector
query each time the significance of
these is all these p queries get
answered based on the same mini batch
okay so this is important because in a
standard sq model
you know you can just ask uh each query
separately i mean that you don't gain
anything by asking a bunch of queries
together in fact you only lose here it
is important that we're actually going
to um answer
these vector queries all in the same uni
batch
okay
sort of so there's a
honest sq there's a um
uh we initially called this honest skew
and then we saw that honestly skew we
felt it's a bit of a
misnomer so endless dispute in the the
paper referring to honest to skill in
honesty
the uh
the the queries are one bit queries and
there's no accuracy parameter and that
actually makes a significant difference
in terms of the result
no you it's not actually the same once
you you can't once you uh
it makes a big difference because the
the whether you answer them based on the
same uh batch or not and also when you
deal with accuracy
so these differences it's not i mean we
can talk about that later
but uh the honest skew model is uh is
significantly different from what we
have here and see the results are also
uh different and again it does make a
difference uh
whether you
ask one bit queries or not
okay there are already separations
between audiences
certainly there are separations between
honest executives but they're not the
same uh separation system
yes okay so um
and again our goal here is not just one
emphasize our goal here i think it's an
interesting by-product but our goal here
is not so much to separate being honest
to q and sq our goal is to understand
gradient descent
okay and this model directly corresponds
to great interest okay in the following
sense so the way our analysis proceeds
is in two steps and the first step what
we do is we're gonna we
we simulate any mini batch sq algorithm
using the uh minibatch sgb and this
simulation is pretty straightforward
like the the precis the mini batch sdg
precision corresponds to the meaning bet
to the precision here and the mini batch
size corresponds to the mini batch here
and we have like a completely direct
correspondence kind of one to one
correspondence and so we can say that
the learning power of learning with uh
mini batch sgd is exactly the same as a
learning power of learning with the uh
with this mini batch sq model and then
and then this allows us now to forget
about gradient descent and just ask
about how how is this mini batch sq
model related to pack and sq
okay um okay so let's uh briefly see how
actually how much time do i have because
i don't know when we started
so why don't you check okay so
let's keep going okay so
okay i hope you brought lunch with you
okay so um okay so how are we gonna uh
simulate uh
um how are we gonna simulate sorry so
because how do we do the few steps or
our goal is to take a minibatch sql game
so uh adam comes up with some uh um uh
mini some uh mini batch sq algorithm and
basically i can ask you algorithms
answers queries in this form and now i
want to implement that algorithm using
grading descent so i i take adam's
algorithm and i want to come up with a
single objective function sorry not
objective function a single model right
parameterized model that if you do if
you run uh mini batch sgd on the loss of
my model it'll do pretty much exactly
what adam's mini batch studio mini batch
sq algorithm would do okay and so the
core of what we want to simulate is we
just need to see how to simulate
statistical queries
and that's kind of easy i can gradient
this already statistical query right the
answer to a gradient to mini batch
gradient is already statistical query we
just be able to be able to encode any
statistical query that we want and and
that's relatively easy um so the maybe
main observation here which is fairly
straightforward like if we have uh a
linear uh function um
if our model uh
is linear um with some uh
uh
uh as a linear function of the parameter
of the parameters w uh
uh where the linear function it's some
function of x times w
then this the the the gradient is going
to be correspond to uh this exactly as
function of x right this is the gradient
here with respect to w the only thing we
want to need to worry about is also this
this involves x it doesn't involve y um
and so we have to make sure that we get
uh the gradient is zero so the the type
of queries we actually answer and this
turns out to be sufficient our queries
where either were uh are zero whenever
the label is zero or zero never the
label is one and that we can control by
making sure that the output of the model
is either zero and one and so we don't
get any gradient right the loss is
already optimal uh for the great label
we're outputting uh and we only get
a gradient when the label is the
opposite in this case stable equals zero
so the details here i mean you can work
this this i think you can look at this
later this is not very complicated so
here's a question
okay um
and so the basic idea is again i mean if
gradient is a is a
is a grain we can encode any statistical
queries in that but now we have to
encode a sequence of statistical queries
and so that gets a bit hairy but there's
nothing fundamentally uh
involved here i'm not going to uh go
into over all the details and basically
we set the model up so that
each time you the the function knows
kind of how many queries we already
answered based on how many so there's a
parameter corresponding to the answer of
each query and each time the query
depends the the we're going to have a
linear dependence just on the parameters
uh
that are going to receive the answer for
this query and
the linear function that's going to
multiply them so the function is going
to multiply them locally it's a fixed
fixed in terms of the parameters based
on you know how many parameters are
already non-zero okay so the important
thing is that the gradient only is is
very local so we may just need this to
hold um
uh
locally for each kind of type of weight
vector based on how many parameters we
already set okay so you can construct
this there's a bunch of like really
annoying issues to deal with uh like the
parameter is drifting and uh all kinds
of stuff like that but the the good news
is that now we only have to do this once
instead of every time you want to
analyze grading center on your own
okay um
okay so what we get here is that um we
can simulate any uh sq algorithm using
some differentiable model i didn't even
mention neural nets right this is a
crazy differentiable model right this is
defined in terms of this uh the the
the choices that adam is going to make
in his sq algorithm okay but
making this into a neural net is
actually the easy part right so what's
going on here i have some function this
function depends uh what we define here
is just some function that depends on
the uh um
uh
on the inputs the x and a bunch of
parameters i can think of these
parameters as just weights going on from
a fixed bias
you know for fixed uh bias term uh to
the function okay and now the key is
that if adam's algorithm is actually a
polytime algorithm then that means i can
implement all these decisions of which
query to make and all the queries
themselves uh using a polytime algorithm
which means using a polytime circuit
which means they can implement them
using a neural net they're using a
polytone neural net so that means that
this entire function here i can actually
implement using some reasonably sized
neurons okay and that gives me the fact
that i can now uh this means that i what
i described here is actually a neuron or
can be implemented as in your owner
that means that if the algorithm again
there are two parts here one is that any
sq algorithm no matter if it's poly time
computable or not can be simulated by
grading this sentence differentiable
model but if this algorithm this sq
algorithm is polytime computable then
furthermore this differentiable model
can be implemented in your oldness
yeah
no it's okay okay
very very crazy ridiculous ridiculous
ridiculous ridiculous completely also
you really need stochastic gradient
ah okay okay okay wait wait wait wait so
that we didn't talk about yet so what we
what we talked about so far is just how
to implement mini batch sq algorithms
using mini batch sgv
so we didn't touch at all the issue of
stochasticity
right so so that's intentionally
separating between those two things
right so what we what we i in order for
this simulation i don't need
stochasticity
in this in this simulation i'm gonna
need exactly the same stochasticity as
your sq algorithm is going to need your
sq algorithm your mini batch sql
algorithm is going to use b samples at
each iteration which is exactly a
stochastic i'm going to use i'm going to
use b samples for each step of success
the gradient descent
has to be very small no this is true for
any b
for any mini batches you're going to run
mini batch sq with some b with some
batch size
right
if you're going to use full batch i'm
going to use full batch yes i don't need
any stochastic to simulate right okay
so i we didn't yet touch the causticity
at all like this simulation has nothing
to do with stochasticity right whatever
sample
i need to be able to basically kind of
look at an example
no no no no the computable function okay
let me clarify the computable function
you're assimilating here is a
deterministic function it has no i mean
it could have randomization it's
actually just makes a bit more
complicated because i need to add some
random bits but for now let's say your
sq algorithm is a deterministic
algorithm
right so each query is a deterministic
function of the answers to the preceding
queries
this deterministic function right
because you're embedding this with an
sql okay
because i'm bidding with it
again i'm taking your your mini
bachelor's q algorithm
i'm just saying that you know there are
problems that you know we know that you
cannot uh implement with full batch sq
of course of course but that's not what
work but that's not again i'm not
showing you here so far i didn't tell
you that you can do anything with sgb
what i'm telling you is anything you can
do with meaning about yourself
yes exactly exactly right okay so now
the second question in fact so right so
what i'm saying is just minimize q is
exactly the same as me about yesterday
they're basically exactly the same
process right and so now what adam is i
think asking is like okay fine so how
does this relate to actually sq learning
and uh
impact learning right so right
the thing is that now when we go to
answer this we can now completely forget
about grading descent we can now just
ask you know how powerful are these mini
batches cute chords right and as a
function of the sample size
of the batch size okay okay and the
answer is as follows so first of all
the one thing we can already say is you
can it's pretty easy to simulate sq
using mini batch sq right so you can
answer for any sq algorithm if you
haven't asked
and you know it still has an sq
algorithm that actually expects answers
that are within some tolerance of a
population i can simulate any answer to
to still and by with a sequence with
just by averaging a bunch of mini
batches queries until they get the
you know as long as the numerical
tolerance is not any worse than
intolerance once i can actually answer
any statistical query on the population
by averaging a bunch of uh mini batch
statistical queries so i can simulate
uh sq with minibatch sq
and and so this is inside here so this
already tells us that um
mini batch sgd with any mini batch size
right so no full batch or or you know
huge batch in a population with a small
batch can at the very least simulate a
skew so that's already like useful
result i mean that means that for
example for the separation result i
showed you before i didn't really have
to destroy the network it was enough for
me to say i can learn but i'm sorry i
can learn um
sparse buyers priorities with sq done i
never have to show you a network i never
have to like analyze grading descent and
send for all these other separation
results between kernels and uh
uh kernels and uh differentiable
learning okay they're all actually sq
learnable okay
um but can we go beyond sq okay so how
far can we hope to go so definitely
everything here is included inside pack
right i can consolidate all of these
things using you know but with samples
so everything lives inside uh pack
learning can we actually get to pac
learning and this is maybe to me that
was the most surprising thing here um
is showing that mini batch skew can
actually simulate pack learning as long
as
uh we have this relationship between the
batch size and the tolerance so as long
as the the batch size is not too large
relative to the tolerance so the
tolerance is not too coarse relative to
the batch size okay so we need the batch
size to be one over the tolerance
tolerance one over bad size whatever you
want to prefer to think about it and in
that case um
then this goes all the way out to uh
pack learning and we can similarly pack
and again this result is a result about
mini batch sq but it translates directly
to a statement about grading descent but
mini batch building descent does that
adam is that kind of what was bothering
you before and this is where the
stochastic comes in okay i then okay so
i still have to show you how to do this
but it's a statement of the result
yeah you're okay if you're surprised
that this is possible i was also
surprised so i don't know my i was
actually always when i give this talk
now it's obvious to me so i'm i'm
expecting all the audience to sit and
say oh this is obvious you know maybe
this is obviously it wasn't obvious to
me um okay and the question is
i would say from prior work by
ava and send it i would say you know
it's known that
uh if you allow me individual example
access right if maybe that's equal to
one but now i'm saying you can do it
with any media
that had nothing to do with
stochasticity
that that for example all of these lower
bounds will still hold for sq plus noise
it was more that they're actually you
know the reason why you can start to
implement all of these
all of these
classes that i get to actually look at
example
so i i would so i would actually uh so i
think from my perspective the main
message here is that's not the case it's
actually not because of that i can
implement
i can actually implement anything with
computation the the issue of computation
and what computations they do is
completely separate
from uh the issue of uh the media size
in sq
it doesn't have to do with the fact that
sgd you know like
you know like i would say conventional
wisdom is that you know sgd is
advantageous over gd because there's
some
noise you know it's allowing you to
escape
but but you know that's not what's going
on here it's not that there's some kind
of noise that's allowed
function
okay
you don't need the noise to compute the
functions the issue is not computing the
functions enough that's okay let's let's
talk about at the end because this is i
think an important issue but they want
to get okay and the question is now how
far can we push it do we i mean do we in
fact need this tolerance maybe we can do
it with less tolerance even
and the complementary result is this is
almost tight uh when uh the mini batch
size times the square tolerance at least
is larger and we do need here to be
larger than uh log dimension
uh then we cannot go beyond this cube
right so there's uh so we kind of
characterize exactly when this mini
batch is 3d when is it as small as sq
and when is it large is [ __ ] learning
and there's some regime in between
uh a relatively narrow regime that we
don't know and it's it's definitely you
know
i actually don't know what the answer
there
okay um let me okay assuming i do have a
few minutes okay maybe i'll do this very
quickly so maybe the there is there are
two kind of i think uh uh um confusion
here one is the simulation and again i
think that the important thing to this
is maybe part of the discussion with
adam the simulation has absolutely
nothing to do with stochasticity
sampling anything it's just like taking
these specific queries and directly
implementing within grading descent and
the other
uh is being able to to
leverage these mini batches queries to
actually simulate any pack algorithm and
the key here is what we essentially have
to do is we're able to extract samples
right once they can extract single
samples then of course i can simulate
pack i can just you know extract the
sample and then feed that into my pack
algorithm so how do i extract samples
and this is i think to me the the kind
of uh uh
interesting technical part here right so
we want a procedure that performs a
sequence of midi batches quick queries
and outputs a sample sampled exactly
from the source distribution so i only
have access to source distribution to
the mini batches queries they can do
this um
so um i'm actually okay actually you
know something i'm not going to actually
tell you how to do this
let me just tell you that it is possible
to do
so this is the algorithm i'm not going
to go over it
we can maybe at the end if we have time
we can go over it but the point is there
is a relatively simple algorithm uh that
with uh order n n is a number of input
bits or in
every roughly order and iterations it
spits out a sample and when it spits out
a sample it's exactly sampled from the
source distribution
okay um so this is uh the key here okay
let me um
go
um let's go back though to exactly what
we showed and what's the actually how
much i mean seriously how much time i
have because i could actually go for
that but i don't know i feel like my
watch i'm like feel like i'm way over
time
five minutes okay so soon let's me go on
and then that's fine okay
um
okay so let's uh uh
uh so let's summarize uh uh what we have
so again what what we can say is that as
long as the
uh
tolerance i'm just repeating the same
thing already for the third time but
just to make sure you know we're all on
the same page right the tolerance is
smaller to the batch size i can simulate
pack um this result again is completely
uh general has nothing to do with
computation right so this is uh i can
simulate with some differentiable model
i can simulate any
method based on m samples and same
method just like a function from a
mapping from those samples to the output
but if the method is polytime computable
uh then i can also do this within your
own okay
and
if the tolerance is high i cannot go
beyond the skew but anyway i can at
least
do a skew okay
okay so again this is uh
just correcting a bit maybe the picture
we might have had before based on the
manual and columns result that um the
simulation does not actually uh strongly
rest in the mini batch size being one
right so i can simulate sq which is
quite a bit
with any mini batch size and also with
any mini batch size i can also simulate
uh pack but i do need to be a bit uh
careful with the tolerance i mean i do
need my toilet and the number of bits to
be logarithmic in the mini batch size
okay if however i have finite precision
then again i
get this
separation that once my mini batch size
is too high i stopped being able to
simulate pack and i can just simulate
ask you okay
uh what about full batch gradient
decentral again so one of the ways to
think about this though there's an
advantage of mini batch sgd over full
battery in any sense a full batch
grinding is a bit different than using a
batch size of infinity right and we
still have a limited batch size but we
keep using the same examples so again
here you can take the exact same
two-step approach in the first step
using the exact same simulation we can
simulate a model like a full batch uh
sq model so now this is you know the
same as a skew but i answer all the
queries using the same sample of
examples right
in the simulation results are exactly
the same so again we don't have to worry
about all the gradient descending nasty
grading in some details we're just back
to asking you know what can we actually
do with this full batch of skew
and
and
in some sense the the sample extraction
is is even easier here right because i i
i keep having access to the same and
same batch i can ask you as many queries
as i want on the same uh adaptively on
the same number of examples so in some
sense it's much more powerful actually
than before
and in particular uh we can at least do
what we did before um
which is extract you know we can
extract samples uh
if the mini if the batch size is uh the
tolerance is small relative to the bed
size so again if the tolerance is less
than one over m um then we can extract
samples and gradually extract all the
samples in the sample and simulate
basically just recover what we're doing
in this case we're actually doing
something even stronger we can even draw
without replacement and even completely
recover the sample
that we haven't just run back
i should say that here um
there is
what's going on with the it's not trying
okay so the lower bound we also have a
lower bound here but the lower bound
here is much more disappointing so i'm
going before we had a lower bound that
says that if um
uh
um
the
where is it um if the batch size times
the uh
tolerance squared is high then we cannot
go beyond this q and we have kind of a
similar lower bound here
but the difference is now this min the
website's times of color and squared has
to be higher than something that's
polynomial in the number of iterations
the number of parameters
and this is a super weak floor and then
we can go beyond the skew but this is a
very weak lower bound because it you
know for any minibar size intolerance
maybe i can make up for it by just
running longer having more iterations
okay
and this lower bound does not preclude
it and i
i actually think um
you know the question here is i think
it's important interesting question not
so much for grading descent more maybe
for privacy or other applications
actually i've looked a bit at privacy
i'm a bit surprised this is not
something at least directly covered
maybe you can correct me maybe it is um
can i actually with if i have access to
the same batch of examples can i extract
samples even with any any polynomial
batch size even with constant tolerance
right so does that somebody know the
answer actually if they give you s you
know these
sq type uh uh access to sample like you
can calculate averages in the sample
with fixed tolerance can you extract uh
can you extract this as a single sample
or something okay i don't know anyway um
anyway the conclusions about uh um so
what can you tell us about uh
about grading descent versus um
uh
um
uh about uh full veteran descending and
we can see that we can actually simulate
even similar attack with full batch
granny scent with enough tolerance again
not so much crazy tolerance on a
logarithmic number of bits of precision
but if we do fix the precision then at
some point we do get
um
um
uh we do need to uh to use you know do
we have a benefit for mini batch and
again the main caveat for all of these
results is adam already mentioned these
networks are ridiculously crazy networks
with super specific initialization right
i'm coding here i mean i don't get you
know if
uh student starts with a pack algorithm
and then adam implements it with a
mini batch sq algorithm and then i
implement it with a grading descent my
on the neural net my initialization from
a neural net encodes the circuit that
implements adam's sq algorithm that
implements stills pack algorithm okay
that's a completely crazy initialization
and not something we'd ever use
so nevertheless what um
so
um
and i think it's important to keep that
coverage in mind when you think about
you know what does all this teach us
like what did we do all this okay so
and because of this caveat i'm not
entirely sure what this teaches us to be
to be honest right so
the questions the questions we're trying
to uh to answer here you know there's
come some interesting question here um
like
yeah wait um
right so
um
what this shows is in some sense first
of all sgd can kind of be on go beyond
the skew so we think about when i think
usually about you know training with
gradients and stochastic gradients and i
usually think about you know just what
i'm doing is essentially some form of
skew and what we see here this is not
true okay you can definitely go beyond
the skew even with large batch sizes
right losing precision but again is this
really true i mean can we really is the
power of neural nets by the fact that
let us go beyond the skew i mean
this doesn't seem to be the case and i
think it's an interesting question in
realistic networks can you actually go
beyond this cube
right so you can definitely even i can't
even expect to simulate all of sq but
can i i do i effectively is this effect
of using small batch sizes to go beyond
or
finite batch sizes to go beyond excuse
something we actually you know leverage
in practice and i have no idea i
actually even answer this i'm not sure
you know this work this only shows kind
of like plausibility possibility of that
i wouldn't even say plausibility
the other question is about what maybe
adam was loaded before the power of
stochasticity and using uh small batch
sizes do we actually gain by using small
batch sizes right so there's a lot of
discussion
we do and
um
what we uh um
what we see here is that yes and no so
on one hand we don't really you need to
use pure sgp we can actually simulate
pack as i said even without
stochasticity and algorithm full batches
with full batch grid and descent
on the other hand we do see some um
some benefit of stochasticity if we use
finite precision and you know in
practice we do use finite precision and
now we have to ask you know
is the precision we use really
logarithmic in the batch size or not
they don't exactly know how to answer
these questions for new realistic
networks
and
um
and also
we don't we didn't preclude the fact
that you might even be able to simulate
pack even with constant uh with full
batch gradient instead actually in some
sense maybe even have more power right
you maybe can even simulate pac using
constant tolerance right so in some
sense maybe you just can lose by having
stuck insisting on stochasticity here
um but again the main caveat here is
that all this is with these crazy
networks and i think that this tells us
frankly fairly little on
the role of stochasticity in practice
and there's been several other papers
also recently that from very very
different directions look at this
question which i think is a super
important question about really
does stochasticity help us i mean do we
actually gain by the fact that we're
doing stochastic grading descent as
opposed to like full batch or more
deterministic gradients and do we gain
by having small batches in terms of so
we definitely gain by reducing runtime
that's very clear right that we
understand very well but if we don't
care about runtime do i actually care do
it gain in terms of generalization
ability
and i think the the
jury is still out to this there's
several papers that show that in
principle you could gain a paper by uh
uh changing and uh bartlett and jordan
uh that showed that the implicit bias
can be affected by uh uh stochasticity
interesting ways and i think another
super interesting paper by uh um
uh
sakari kali in uh uh street iran uh
recent paper
that showed that for
a certain type of uh stochastic convex
optimization problems they're actually
learnable using stochastic gradients and
but not learnable using erm in a very
kind of a strong way again this shows
that there exists instances that uh for
which sdg really helps but it's
completely these are super artificial
problems again it's not clear whether
this is actually happening in uh um in
problems we actually uh um
you know we actually use and and again i
think that an interesting question is
that emmanuel and some people maybe
maybe even in this room or at least in
this program are looking at is can we
sort of restrict the class of models
we're talking about and say what's
inside so what we kind of see here is
that asking what's learnable okay maybe
that's the one conclusion here but
asking what's learnable with gradients
and on some neural network is maybe not
a very interesting question so we
started by saying that saying
understanding deep learning by asking
what's numbered by erm is not
interesting let's give this the wrong
answer so now we're saying okay what's
involved by grading the center of neural
network and maybe the conclusion here is
this is also not interesting because we
get this very generic results that
really we can do all of sq and maybe
even all of pac that's again not a very
interesting question okay because
clearly it's not like we we can you know
any specific neural network cannot learn
all of you know
all of anything that's back learnable um
and so we need to make even more
restrictions so i'm asking what can we
learn by grading descent on like
homogeneous networks you know whether
it's relatively uniform when
initialization is not crazy and i don't
know how to define initialization it's
not crazy i think this is kind of maybe
uh the most interesting thing here okay
the last thing i wanted to mention is
going circling back to kernels
maybe i'll take another can i drive
another minute
no okay never mind
oops
that's fine so let's uh just in here and
if you want to read more uh both of
those papers and archive thank you
question
um
did you say a little bit more about how
this this relates to the honest excuse
yeah no sorry so so honestly
also and unlike in the in the setting
where it's one bit as well as in the
setting where it's like maybe real value
okay so honest to sku
uh
the honest q model had uh did not have
an accuracy parameter uh but you're only
allowed one bit query per round and in
that case you actually cannot go beyond
this cube
so what's really important here is that
we are allowing uh uh
a polynomial number of uh queries per
round okay and in particular um
it's
uh the
it's not a very high polynomial all we
need is n queries or n plus 1 queries
per round and in some sense
you i can't exactly prove this
but i can argue that if you want to do
extraction you cannot do extraction with
less than
much less than inquiries per round
okay um so now it doesn't mean that you
can simulate pac right but in order to
do the kind of the the type of
extraction we're doing of actually
returning a sample from the distribution
um you
you have to kind of have uh uh
many quarks now
you can the the queries we're doing is
also single bit queries okay uh but we
are limiting the as you saw once you
have once you're allowing multiple bit
and multiple queries the accuracy does
become uh the accuracy does become
important okay because if we didn't
bound the accuracy like honestly the
skew model doesn't bound to accuracy we
can again do anything
and so the the things we're bounding are
a bit different the again the main
result for the honest skew is if you ask
a single bit query at each round you
cannot go beyond this scale
the poster session is at 1 30.
1 30. so we'll see you then hey adam